thank you
get ready to scream with excitement at
this week's killer selections of what to
watch making the cut this week the
scream franchise forces you to use your
other hand to count sequels we also got
Adam Driver facing off against dinosaurs
plus three popular streaming series all
coming to their season end with all the
fungus spreading cyber stalking lie
detecting fun you can imagine and lucky
for you Rotten Tomatoes has a terrible
poker face so you'll know just how we
feel about it on this week's what to
watch
share a certain history
slashing its way into theaters is the
sixth installment in the scream film
franchise that took 20 ticks to get
right and unlike the typical demise of a
ghost face this franchise is looking to
live on currently fresh with a strong 78
on the Tomato Meter with 119 reviews
make sure to check back on the score
throughout the week but for fans of the
franchise it's definitely looking like
another solid entry this time around the
setting may be new as in New York City
instead of good old Woodsboro but many
of the faces will be familiar from past
screen movies stars like Melissa Barrera
Jenna Ortega Hayden Panettiere and
Courtney Cox among others are returning
and don't forget Roger L Jackson the
voice of Ghostface oh no that's the
wrong one and if for whatever reason you
thought this time the reveal of the
killer may be a formula they messed with
just know that Courtney Cox played the
game herself and figured out the killer
during production I loved watching the
actors going wait a minute are you a
good actor are you a good actor acting
like you're acting but she plays the
game behind the scenes she's like I'm
gonna figure it out and yeah
thank you
foreign
also Crash Landing in theaters this week
is the Sci-Fi Adventure 65 and no there
are not 64 other movies to catch up on
and one big reason to watch this one is
that Adam Driver no stranger to sci-fi
leads the way in this film as a pilot
who crashes on what he would discover to
beat Earth 65 million years ago and yeah
you know what that means dinosaurs he
and the only other Survivor played by
Ariana Greenblatt have to deal with all
kinds of gnarly prehistoric dangers to
survive plus 65 was written and directed
by Scott Beck and Brian Woods who also
co-wrote a quiet place so we know
they've got the skills for this type of
flick they also served as producers
alongside Sam Raimi whose resume would
definitely be a two-pager if people were
still promoting resumes these days talk
about prehistoric am I right there's no
halfway with this
finish what we started
wrapping up an infectiously popular
season this week is HBO's The Last of Us
hailed as one of if not the greatest
video game adaptation of all time the
season 1 critics consensus credits this
new series for retaining the most
addictive aspects of its beloved Source
material while digging deeper into the
story making it binge-worthy TV that
ranks among the all-time greatest video
game adaptations see told you it's right
there over the last two months the
stories of Joel and Ellie as well as
other key figures from the game have
captivated audiences with their layered
mature and heartbreaking Humanity
however the jury is still up for its
final episode will it nail what many
gamers considered to be one of the most
powerful and divisive endings to a story
ever told well unlike those nasty
clickers you'll just have to wait and
see the good news is regardless it's
already being renewed for season two all
things considered we're safe and sound
for now
but one last thing the biggest and
greatest
[Music]
I am not some cold blooded
psycho coming back with part two of its
fourth season this week is the
psychological Thriller you and this is
obvious but if you haven't caught up
with part one then you're gonna want to
especially after that mid-season twist
where Joe is he and you are he is you
are we and we are not all together after
that sorry the show explains the better
I promise and after three certified
fresh Seasons the first half of the
fourth is coming in fresh above 90 on
the Tomato Meter as well and much of the
praise begins and ends with our favorite
romantic Killer Joe played by Penn
Badgley who directs the penultimate
Episode by the way killer Talent playing
a talented killer how's that for poetry
you
foreign
apparently because the season finale of
another hit show Poker Face is also
being dealt out this week this murder
mystery series from peacock was created
by Ryan Johnson yes The Man Behind The
Knives Out franchise and stars Natasha
Leone as a Vegas casino worker who goes
on the run and winds up solving crimes
from town to town with her unique
ability to tell someone's lying the
certified fresh inaugural season has
been a huge hit so far hovering around
99 on the Tomato Meter with plenty of
love being thrown Leon's way and top
critic Darren franage from Entertainment
Weekly wrote the Thrills can feel old
school but by successfully carving out a
third way between Network franchises and
Prestige Gloom Poker Face announces
itself as the crime show of the Year
okay that'll do it don't be too sad
about all these Show seasons ending
there's absolutely no shortage of shows
whatsoever at any time we'll be okay oh
one last big thing the Oscars are this
weekend Sunday March 12th 8 PM Eastern 5
p.m Pacific on AB PC I'd be so fired if
we missed that and remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and until
next week everybody stay fresh
foreign
[Music]